Good evening.
I'm John Harbison, part
of a large team helping
to survive the well-deserved
sabbatical of Fred Harris.
And we are here to give audible
thanks for his leadership
and to present some
pieces of unusual cast.
This is the first
ever FJE concert
consisting entirely of
arrangements and compositions
by present and former
members of the band.
It is also the
first presentation
of the group in living memory
with the absence of Fred
Harris--
a near impossible feat.
We offer the concert
in his honor,
of course-- in his spirit.
The well-oiled
Fred-less machine has
been kept humming through
the rehearsal period,
mainly through the artistic
and diplomatic savvy
of Peter Goddard, our pianist.
[APPLAUSE]
Only a few of us tonight
ever heard the band
under Herb Pomeroy,
but among those would
be our guest
conductor tonight, who
has been close to the
band for many, many years
as player, composer,
and arranger.
He was the first
leader after Herb.
We're especially glad to be
hearing four of his tunes
tonight.
Please join us in
welcoming Jamshied Sharifi.
[APPLAUSE]
[JAZZ MUSIC PLAYING]
Thank you.
You heard from Baba
Ogunlade on trumpet and--
[APPLAUSE]
Zhi Wei Gan--
Zhi Wei Gan also on trumpet.
[APPLAUSE]
Before that, we heard from
Julia Fiksinski [INAUDIBLE]
and Tony Terrasa and a little
bit from Peter Godart as well.
It's a great pleasure
to be here again.
As some of you know, I used
to do this in another life.
I started conducting
this band in 1985,
which sounds prehistoric--
before most of these people
were born.
In fact, I was about their
age when that happened.
So it's been a great
delight to do this again,
to be back here again, mostly to
be in front of these musicians,
because they're really
phenomenal both musically
and as human beings.
And it's just a lovely,
lovely experience to be here.
As John Harbison
pointed out, we're
doing music that's all
coming from inside the band,
and some of it is very
much student directed.
The next piece, which is
written by Tony Terrasa,
will also be conducted by him,
and it features him, I think.
Who else is playing on this?
We've got Kevin and
we've got Julia.
Oh, OK, Julia again
will be playing,
and Kevin Costello
will play trumbone.
This is Fluffy.
[APPLAUSE]
[SNAPPING]
One, two, one, two, three, four.
[JAZZ MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
We're going to continue with a
piece written by our guitarist,
Richard Oates, for a smaller
ensemble, a chamber ensemble,
called Insignificant Figures.
[JAZZ MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you again.
That was Richard's piece,
Insignificant Figures.
We're going to
finish with a piece
by Peter Godart who
plays piano and has also
been a part of the team
running the band during Fred's
sabbatical.
As you know, Fred is--
or as you may know,
Fred is writing a book.
Can I tell you?
Can I tell this?
Is this a secret?
Yes, you can.
Go ahead.
Oh, I can.
OK, good.
Fred is writing a book about
the Lion of Boston jazz,
Herb Pomeroy, who,
as you may know,
was a really
amazing jazz figure.
He played with Charlie
Parker, with Stan Kenton,
with Lionel Hampton.
He was a fixture
at Berkeley, and he
also was really the
founder of this band
and ran it for 22 years.
So I'm really looking
forward to that book.
Peter's been a big part of
keeping this team together.
This next piece that he wrote
will feature, well, a lot of us
in the band, but
Talia Khan as well.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
And it's called Wisdom.
[JAZZ MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) Searching for
wisdom in the mirror.
Can't see past yourself to
get a clearer point of view.
Don't you find it
ain't that mirror?
[INAUDIBLE] understand
[INAUDIBLE]..
Will never understand.
[INAUDIBLE] just like a dancer.
[INAUDIBLE] again.
Don't you worry, though.
He probably can't control
his nature [INAUDIBLE]
[JAZZ MUSIC]
[WORDLESS SINGING]
(SINGING) Seek for
wisdom in the mirror.
Can't see past yourself to
get a clearer point of view.
Don't you find it
ain't that mirror?
Wisdom takes its time and
there is nothing you can do.
Get outside your head.
In time you'll understand though
you know it's a true thing.
A universal true thing.
The universal true thing, you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much Talia Khan,
Brandon Allen, Kevin Costello,
Peter Godart's piece, "Wisdom."
We will be back with another set
of great music from the band.
Thank you so much for coming.
We'll see you soon.
Bye.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
[JAZZ MUSIC]
Thank you, Richard
Oates, [INAUDIBLE],,
We're going to
continue with a piece
by a dear friend of mine,
Markus Sieber, who has
a project that he calls Aukai.
And this is not music
that one would typically
hear played by a big band.
But I was intrigued
by his records
and wanted to try a
version of one of his songs
with this band.
And they're doing
a fantastic job.
This is "Soplo del Sueno."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Switch it on, please.
Markus Sieber's
"Soplo del Sueno."
We're going to continue with a
piece written by our own Kevin
Costello, yes.
There's some argument
over the title, right?
It's in the program
as "Alexis Dream."
We'll just go with that.
We'll just go with that, OK.
It has also been called
"Alexis's Dream."
But whatever works.
Oh, yes.
And there are a couple of people
who are not in the program.
Isn't that correct?
We are very blessed to
have Evan Ziporyn join us
on clarinet tonight.
[APPLAUSE]
He is an absolute
clarinet luminary.
But he made the time
to learn the music
and sit in with us,
which is wonderful.
And we have the incredible
Sarah Simpson on flute.
I think everybody else
is listed in the program.
But it's fair to point them out.
This piece will feature
Erik Strand on bass.
And, Kevin, you're
playing on this as well?
Yeah.
You are?
OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
Lovely.
Here we go.
"Alexis Dream."
[MUSIC - "ALEXIS DREAM"]
Erik Strand, Tony Terrasa,
Kevin Costello's "Alexis Dream."
I'd like to thank you
all very much for coming.
It's been such a
pleasure to play for you.
It's been a very
personal pleasure for me
to be in this hall again and
to be with these people again.
They're lovely human
beings and lovely musicians
and really treasured
every minute with them.
We are going to close with
yet another original piece,
this time by Brandon Allen.
It is-- well, it's an original
arrangement of the Bud Powell
standard "Un Poco Loco."
And it features Peter
Godart on piano.
Oh, yes.
I suppose I should.
OK.
This is a Fred tradition, right?
OK, that means I have to
remember everybody's name,
right?
I'm going to try.
OK, it's only been
five weeks, or I
should say seven
rehearsals-- six rehearsals.
Let's see.
We'll start with the front row.
I did introduce Sarah and Evan.
Rogers Epstein on tenor.
Brian-- give me a clue.
Wait, Brian Chow?
No?
Yes, I got it.
Amazing.
[INAUDIBLE] Richardson?
OK.
[INAUDIBLE] OK.
Brandon Allen, we--
Alexis Kim, trombone.
We've already met
that guy, Kevin.
[INAUDIBLE]---- I might have
to use my cheat sheet.
Is that OK?
Please.
Sorry about this.
[INAUDIBLE]
I'm close.
[INAUDIBLE] Kumar.
I knew that.
I was almost there.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
You met Z. You met Baba.
Mickey Hansen.
OK, Jake-- Jake Kinney, OK.
Brian Luster and Tommy Kraus.
OK, rhythm.
You met Richard.
You met Peter.
You met Julia.
Dominic Skinner on base.
You met Erik back there.
Chase Voegeli on drums.
And [? Kuko. ?] [? Kuko ?]
Dala is doing this sound.
And I did have spent a
little moment in the house
to tell you-- and I can tell
you how great the sound is.
I've done a few projects with
[? Kuko, ?] including the Jacob
projects and the Bowie thing
and the Great Clarinet Summit.
And his attention to detail
is such a relief for all of us
and really creates the world
that you're hearing out there.
Thank you so much,
[? Kuko, ?] for all
that you're doing for us.
And you met him at the top.
But I really have to think
John Harbison for all
he's done for this
semester stepping
in for Herb and really, for
decades of love and attention
that he's given to the
MIT musical community.
He's such a great asset.
And if you find him,
show him your love.
He's really such an
asset to all of us.
And, Fred, thank you.
Thank you for this.
I know you're out
there somewhere.
Oh, he's back there, OK.
It's been a great pleasure.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK, this is "Un Poco Loco."
Thanks.
One, one, one, one.
[MUSIC - "UN POCO LOCO"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much for coming.
And we will be
playing again May 9,
although with a different
team, I believe.
Laura, Jay, will be I think,
running the show at that point.
Thank you so much
again for coming,
and we'll see you next time.
Bye bye.
[APPLAUSE]